- Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
I'm Kevin Belk.
[APPLAUSE]
SETH MACFARLANE: Here?
Right here?
KEVIN BELK: You're right here.
SETH MACFARLANE: Yeah.
KEVIN BELK: Welcome
Seth MacFarlane,
who is the show creator, writer,
executive producer, and star
of the show.
Liz Heldens, executive producer
and writer, David A. Goodman,
executive producer, Brannon
Braga, executive producer;
Howard Berger, makeup; and
Joseph Porro, wardrobe.
So welcome everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN BELK: Welcome.
So we have some featurettes.
But first of all, congrats
on Season 2 pick up.
SETH MACFARLANE: Thank you.
We'll start off really quickly.
So Seth, we'll start with you.
We know what you do on the show,
but talk about the genesis,
where this idea came from.
SETH MACFARLANE: I've always
been a huge fan of sci-fi
in many different forms.
And it had been a while
since I had seen something
on television that was episodic
from start to finish, like
"The Twilight Zone," like "Star
Trek," where I was being told
a story, a brand new story
that had a beginning, middle,
and end all on its
own on a weekly basis.
And I miss that.
And I kind of wanted
it back, because that's
what I remember watching.
And there's a lot of great
serialized sci-fi out there,
but there's really
nothing that presents you
with the new idea of the
week, and that was what
we're out to do with this show.
And at the same time,
obviously, I come out of comedy.
And you know, the other
thing I had not seen
was a sort of aggressive
casualization of life onboard
a spaceship, where people
kind of talk over each other
and behave in a not so formal
way, as I would imagine
is what day to day life is
like in the actual military.
So it's where there's moments
of realism, where it's just
people behaving like
people, where they're not
always so buttoned up.
So you know, those are sort
of the ingredients that
were, I think,
foremost in my mind
when I was coming
up with this idea.
KEVIN BELK: Great.
And Liz, we'll start
with you and go around.
But just what are your roles
in the film, on the TV series,
sorry.
LIZ HELDENS: I'm a writer.
SETH MACFARLANE: You're an
executive producer, too, Liz,
for god's sakes.
LIZ HELDENS: Executive producer.
SETH MACFARLANE: She wrote
this episode tonight.
KEVIN BELK: Oh!
[CHEERING]
KEVIN BELK: Episode 109?
JOSEPH PORRO: Oh, I'm
the costume designer.
[APPLAUSE]
BRANNON BRAGA: I'm
a writer as well.
DAVID A. GOLDEN: Writer as well.
HOWARD BERGER: And makeup
and all the creatures
for the shows.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN BELK: OK, so we
have a featurette that's
going to get us into this.
So if we can cue up video one.
Short.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The coolest thing
to me that we're doing
is we are doing model work.
- Seth really wanted
a subconscious
feel of a real model, as opposed
to a computer generated one.
We put the best of
both worlds together,
designed it on the computer,
being able to print it out
from within, and then
we have this action
object that we could shoot.
- It's not bad, right?
- No, it's good.
You paint some
flames on the side,
maybe like a rainbow unicorn.
You got something.
- The more complex shots
of the Orville are CGI.
But when you see the Orville
fly by, or if its a close shot,
or if it doesn't have to do
something really acrobatic,
those are models.
We built an actual
model of the Orville.
There's something that still
feels artificial and cartoonish
about a CGI spaceship.
Even now there's nothing
that really smells
like a model that's real and has
been designed by human hands.
As a sci-fi nerd,
that's probably--
might be the biggest
thrill for me.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN BELK: It is so--
SETH MACFARLANE: I'm
sitting right here.
I could've just told you that.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN BELK: It was on page 2.
But no, it's so cool to
see models in action.
I didn't realize that there
were models being used
and such practical effects.
And it's so, so cool to
see that brought back.
It's really like an old
film thing that really
is replaced by CGI these days.
So that was really important
for you to really have in there.
So did that take some convincing
of executive producers at all
to go that route versus the CG?
SETH MACFARLANE:
I mean, it was--
you can't do it for
the entire series.
It's too costly.
But for things like flybys
that you use every week, where
it's just establishing shots of
the ship, it actually becomes--
it's twofold.
It becomes economically
helpful, because you
can reuse these same shots.
And it just looks, you know,
it's actual light hitting
an actual surface, which is--
it is still-- particularly
on a television budget,
it is still hard
to duplicate that.
I mean, and our team
does a great job.
They have fooled
me more than once.
But I don't know.
I had that ILM book
when I was a kid,
and with all the pictures
of all the matte painters,
and the model designers,
and the creature designers,
and the set designers.
And knowing that that thing is
actually real, and it's there,
and you can touch it is to
me, I figure this is probably
the last time I'm ever going
to be able to do something
like this in my career.
Because everything
is going to CGI.
So it was a privilege to work
with somebody like Rob Legato,
too, who I've been
a fan of for years.
KEVIN BELK: That's so neat.
And so for the writers, do
you guys when you guys--
when you guys come
into the show,
and then when you got
onto the show, do you
guys find yourself
kind of backed up
against the wall a
little bit sometimes,
where it's we want to do
this, but it's either not
in the budget, or we
don't have this set up.
Or how does it work with kind
of getting into the production
process and storytelling?
LIZ HELDENS: You know, we've
worked on TV for a while,
so you sort of understand when
you're breaking a story what
the limits are in terms of
what you can do on a television
budget.
But what do you sort of
see on this show, I think,
is you see people
like Joseph and Howard
who bring their A game in a way.
So you're seeing
costumes and you're
seeing makeup that
you really don't
see on other really
television shows.
But yet this show is within
the budget of a normal show.
And that same with our-
BRANNON BRAGA: This episode
was a great example.
Those aliens were--
DAVID A. GOLDEN: You want
to answer it, is that it?
BRANNON BRAGA: Well, you
weren't you weren't answering it
correctly.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID A. GOLDEN: All right.
I thought this was
a great example of--
the script did not describe
what the aliens looked like,
and these guys created something
amazing and very memorable.
KEVIN BELK: Liz,
how about for you?
Particularly with this episode,
when you were writing it,
did you work heavily
with Seth on it?
How did that work?
LIZ HELDENS: We all broke
the episode in the room.
And then we pretty much--
it was a pretty thorough break.
And then I just went
away and wrote it.
And then Seth fixed it.
And then, now we're here.
SETH MACFARLANE: I
don't have to fix much.
We're begging her to
come back for season two.
LIZ HELDENS: But I don't
feel like in the room that
there's ever any, I don't know,
Seth creates a pretty nice
space that I don't--
I mean, for me, I
never feel limitations.
I always feel like
the story comes first,
the characters come first, and
then we'll figure it out later.
KEVIN BELK: And what's the
lead time for a lot of this?
Because it's
actually really crazy
to see each episode almost
get more and more complicated.
Especially when the
Krill episode was
the first time that I really--
BRANNON BRAGA: This
is highly unusual.
Every script's
written ahead of time.
LIZ HELDENS: Yeah, it's so nice.
BRANNON BRAGA: Which
just rarely happens.
So when we go into
production, the scripts
have been written and
vetted to a thorough degree.
KEVIN BELK: Is that because of
the production time with makeup
and costumes and the wardrobe
and set making and everything?
DAVID A. GOLDEN: Actually, this
was sort of driven by the fact
that Seth wanted to be
in the writers' room.
And usually a star of a
show, if you're shooting,
he wouldn't have been able
to be in the writers' room.
So last year we wrote
all the scripts,
and that gave us a lot
of flexibility in terms
of laying out the season.
SETH MACFARLANE:
It's also, like, you
know, again, I haven't worked
in hour long live action
television before.
And the idea of shooting
something and spending
12 to 14 hours a day
and killing yourself
to get it done on a
TV shooting schedule
and having it be something
that you haven't polished
to the point at which, you
know, the work is as good as you
can do, I don't think I could
make it through the day.
Well, this is good enough.
Now let's all stay here
14 hours filming it.
No, you want it to be great.
KEVIN BELK: Right.
I mean, so you worked
in live action,
obviously, before with
"Ted" and "A Million Ways
to Die in the West," and now
with "Family Guy" and "American
Dad."
So what did you learn
from that previous work
that you brought
to this that helped
you just get through the process
a little bit better and easier?
SETH MACFARLANE: Well, you
know, certainly VFX integration
is something that, with
"Ted," was, I mean,
that was the whole movie.
Was you're working with a
character who's not there,
and you have to shoot the scene
with a guy who's not there.
So that was certainly
a big part of it.
But it's also the planning.
And dealing with a show
like "Family Guy," you know,
it's an animated show.
So you don't do coverage.
You don't get this shot, then
this shot, then this shot.
You get the shot that you
planned for, and that's it.
So that's something,
coming out of animation
and going into visual
effects, heavy stuff,
is kind of helpful.
Because you do have to decide
before you even do the work.
OK, this is the shot.
You're not going to get to
cut to something different.
And put, like, this is
the special effects shot.
So animation conditions
you to work, making sure
that you're not going to change
your mind later on, that you
know how to plan scenes.
KEVIN BELK: Gotcha.
We were watching that
featurette video, too,
for the wardrobe and makeup,
so let's take a look at that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- To be able to create so many
characters that are tangible,
because nowadays
there's so much CGI
involved in filmmaking
and television shows,
that you would actually have
practical makeups and creatures
and puppets and
mechanical heads.
We were trying to do the
count of how many prosthetic
make ups we had done.
And it's over 5,000.
Playing every single
day was more exciting
than you could ever imagine.
When we first started
designing things,
all I had was the script.
The descriptions were
different than how
the creatures turned out.
Bortus had a big evolution.
The initial design process
was pretty long for Bortus.
It was at least a
five month period.
Once Peter Aiken was hired,
we brought him into KNB,
and we life cast him.
So we had his head, and
we could sculpt on that.
And we went through a
couple different versions.
We never quite hit it.
I came down here, set up
a little sculpting area,
and I just sat and
sculpted for, like,
three or four hours with Seth.
And we finally hit on
what Bortus's look was.
We went ahead, and we
designed it pretty simple.
Peter would come in the morning,
and we'd get him prepped.
And there was a cowl, and
his face would be exposed.
And then we'd glue his
chin on, and then he'd
have a whole front of the face.
What remains Peter is this whole
area here and his eye area.
And the pieces are very
soft, and they were thin,
so he was able to
maneuver his face.
The first time we
had done it, we
had him sit in
front of the mirror
and just move around
and do expressions.
You have to exaggerate
your facial expressions
to some degree, and Peter
was really great with it.
And as a makeup
designer, you want that.
You don't want to have this
giant makeup on somebody,
and they can't act.
He's just such a
great actor, and he
brought that make up to life.
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
KEVIN BELK: So how did you
convince Peter to do this,
that you're going to come
in every day for 14 hours
and wear this heavy
makeup or [INAUDIBLE]..
HOWARD BERGER: It was tough.
But he is so great, though.
He was in for it.
He's one of those actors
who, he understood
what the process was, and that's
half the battle right there.
We do our job in the
morning, myself and Tami Lane
and Garrett Immel.
And he goes through two hours
of makeup every day, probably
applied it like 60
or 70 times, I think,
through the course of the shoot.
And he was always, always
there, and let us do our job,
and then he went to set
and brought it to life.
And that takes a lot, you know.
He never complained, was
really, like, the easiest guy
to deal with.
KEVIN BELK: Joseph, how about
for you, with costuming,
wardrobes in there?
What was the most difficult part
or the most exciting part also
for you when you were
creating these costumes
and the main design
for the flight crew?
JOSEPH PORRO: Well, the alien
stuff they saw in this episode,
I can do that in my sleep.
The crazy stuff is easy.
The uniform, and it's
still a work in progress.
We're still tweaking it.
I don't know if I'll ever
be happy with it, even
on season 7, I'll probably
be doing something.
But that was the biggest
challenge for me.
And it's just these
high tech fabrics.
When you're used to
building suits out
of wool, which form to the
body really beautifully,
and then you get a
high tech sneaker
fabric, which is actually
what they're made out of.
We had them all
custom made for us
in China, these fabrics
for these uniforms.
So that was, I'd say,
the biggest challenge.
And it's an ongoing work.
But it's-- in eight
days, for him to pull,
and for me to-- we
have eight days.
That's what we have.
HOWARD BERGER: That's it.
JOSEPH PORRO: Whoa.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSEPH PORRO: Well,
it's not just us.
I mean, I'm sure that's
every other department, too.
But what's great
about this show,
and you guys can't see this
when you watch the episode,
is behind the camera is one
of the best groups of people
I've worked in in 35 years.
We actually like all our actors.
They actually like us.
And everyone says excuse
me if you do something.
You know, it's just--
so we all are kind of psyched
to go in in the morning.
We really look forward
to getting up at 4:30.
HOWARD BERGER: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSEPH PORRO: Enough.
KEVIN BELK: Well, I mean, when
you were building this crew,
and you worked with a lot
of these people before?
Liz, David, Brannon, you guys
worked together before right?
No?
DAVID A. GOLDEN: Brannon and I--
I worked for Brannon on
one of the "Star Trek."
KEVIN BELK: OK.
DAVID A. GOLDEN: But we'd
never worked with Liz before.
JOSEPH PORRO: I worked
with Brannon on "Next Gen."
He doesn't remember me.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSEPH PORRO: On
season 1, and then
I did Salem with
him for three years.
KEVIN BELK: And then what were
some of your guys' influences,
I guess, when you're
putting together the show?
What, maybe when you were
growing up or whatever,
when you're designing
this, and you're coming up
with the story and stuff,
what influenced you as a kid
to [INAUDIBLE] this
and create the series?
SETH MACFARLANE: I
mean, for me, obviously,
I remember watching
the stuff that Brannon
had written for "Star Trek."
I mean, there's this great,
great, thoughtful science
fiction.
But you know, god, I
mean, I was also a big fan
of "The Twilight Zone."
I watched things
like "Night Gallery."
Like, anything I
could find where
I was being told a story that
would keep me up that night.
I remember reading a Stephen
King story called "The Jaunt."
I think it was in
"Skeleton Crew."
And it kept me up
for, like, two days.
This just blew my mind.
And that's the
kind of stuff that,
in writing science fiction,
that I kind of look for.
Is something that just sits with
me, you know, like a bad meal.
And you know, it's tricky.
And also to make
it human, to make
it something that feels like
it can exist in the real world,
and is not so exotic that
it doesn't take you out
of this kind of day
to day office life
that we're also
trying to create.
KEVIN BELK: And we'll
kind of go down the line.
But who were your influences,
Liz, when you were growing up
and got you into the
[INAUDIBLE] you do?
LIZ HELDENS: Yeah, I knew you
were going to ask me that.
KEVIN BELK: Sorry.
LIZ HELDENS: I watched
"Next Generation."
I watched "Star Trek."
And then I kind of put
that away and watched,
you know, me in my
20s, I just watched
what everybody else watched.
Like, you know, I just
watched all the HBO stuff.
And then, when
this job came up, I
had forgotten all about
"Star Trek Next Gen,"
and then I found it again.
And it was great.
But I don't come
from, I mean, the work
that I've done, I mean, the work
that I've done as a writer is
not like genre stuff.
Like, I come from
"Friday Night Lights"
and super like feely,
feely emotional shows.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN BELK: This has
some of that in there.
LIZ HELDENS: No,
it totally does.
SETH MACFARLANE: It does.
But I think that's--
I mean that's what to me
you want in that room.
I mean, ideally, you
know, you want people
in that room who don't come
from a sci-fi background
as well, who just are fucking
great at writing people.
And you've got to have that.
JOSEPH PORRO: I am a designer.
So I do files.
So I go, I'm all
through deviant art
and all these crazy websites.
And I'm looking--
SETH MACFARLANE: What
are your favorite drugs?
[LAUGHTER]
JOSEPH PORRO: True.
The late '60s [INAUDIBLE].
HOWARD BERGER: That's true.
KEVIN BELK: Fair enough.
How about for you, Howard?
HOWARD BERGER: Yeah,
for me, it was I grew up
on monsters and movies.
So I grew up with the
classic universal monsters.
And then TV was "Twilight
Zone" and "Night Gallery,"
absolutely.
The green thumb one is the one
that got me, when they cut off,
and they--
and still scary.
But just loved
monsters and films.
And about eight
years old, I knew
I was going to grow up and
make monsters for movies.
And I just worked towards
that my entire life.
And you know, this is one of
the many great opportunities
I've had in my 35
year career now.
So it's definitely one of the
most fun things I've ever done.
JOSEPH PORRO: You know, him and
I did our first show together,
my first show as a designer,
first show of his makeup,
back in the mid-'80s.
SETH MACFARLANE: Was what?
JOSEPH PORRO: I'm not going
to tell you the name of it.
It's horrible.
HOWARD BERGER: It's
called "Neon Maniacs."
I was 18 years old.
Yeah, it was-- it's
a real-- it's great.
JOSEPH PORRO: But it was--
HOWARD BERGER: Yeah, it
just came out on Blu-ray.
JOSEPH PORRO: Let's
go back to 1980.
[INAUDIBLE]
SETH MACFARLANE: I'll
take your word for it.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN BELK: David and Brannon?
DAVID A. GOLDEN: I watched
five hours of television a day.
So whatever was on.
Every sitcom, I was a big "Star
Trek" fan, giant, huge giant,
geek "Star Trek" fan.
But sitcoms were also a big
part of what we watched at home.
And I became a sitcom
writer because of that.
SETH MACFARLANE: David wrote
for "The Golden Girls."
He won't tell you that.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID A. GOLDEN: I
don't bring it up,
because I was also fired
by "The Golden Girls."
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN BELK: And Brannon?
BRANNON BRAGA: Any horror movie
I could sneak into as a kid.
I liked horror.
I was a big horror fan.
KEVIN BELK: So
audience questions,
I'm going to pass around this.
Where is it?
Oh, right here, here we go.
SETH MACFARLANE:
Google is not stuffy,
like those other companies.
AUDIENCE: We throw
our microphones.
It's like, yeah, you
just can't see my face
on that [INAUDIBLE].
Anyway--
SETH MACFARLANE:
Now everyone else
is going to want to touch that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I know.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
This is awesome.
We really appreciate it.
So you guys do
realize that you've
made a better "Star Trek" than
all modern "Star Trek," right?
Like, this is a really,
really amazing experience
going through it.
This is actually the first
episode that I've seen,
and now I'm going to rush home
and watch everything else.
But the question I
have is, how did you
go about getting network
approval to actually get this?
Because in my mind,
you have to, like,
admit some pheromone from
your body to go to Fox
and get this done?
So I'm curious, like, what
that approval looked like?
What was the pushback?
What did you sort
of, like, where
was that happy
medium that you had
to reach to get this approved?
SETH MACFARLANE: You know,
it wasn't really that hard.
I mean, Fox, in particular, the
way it was communicated to me,
they had been trying to find a--
"Guardians of the
Galaxy" had been a hit,
the resurgence of "Star Wars."
They'd been trying
to find a sci-fi show
with a comedic element
that would work for them.
And it's a hard thing to do.
And generally, it's
done in the half hour
format, which I always feel
like is part of the problem.
Because you're already
one step removed
from reality, and
to me, the trick
was all right, keep
leaning into the comedy,
and so it's making it harder.
If we leaned a little
bit more into the drama,
and let the comedy
just be garnish,
then maybe that's the answer.
But it really wasn't
that difficult. I mean,
they were excited by the idea.
They felt like it was different.
They liked that it was
episodic, because everything
is serialized now.
And on a network, I
think, look, if it's
Netflix, if it's
Amazon, if it's Hulu,
and you're getting
everything in one big chunk,
and you can binge watch
it, then it's great.
It's hard for me,
sometimes, to invest fully
in serialized
programming on a network,
because I got to wait
a week, you know?
I want to be told an isolated,
independent story, Rod Serling
style.
But it was, I mean,
they were excited
by the idea from the get go.
You know, nowadays, at least, at
Fox, the culture of the people
that I work for
seems to be, look,
we don't know where
the industry is going.
You don't lose any more by
trying to be different and new
and do something that nobody
else is doing, so let's try it.
KEVIN BELK: Great.
Next question?
All the way back
there, back, back row.
You got it.
AUDIENCE: Hit
someone in the head.
KEVIN BELK: You can
do it, throw it.
DAVID A. GOLDEN: This
is very upsetting.
Oh.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if you'd gotten
any kind of input or feedback
from people like William
Shatner or Patrick Stewart
on your show.
Like, has there
been any reaction
from the original "Star Trek"
members or from "Star Trek
Next Gen?"
I was a big fan of that show.
SETH MACFARLANE: I mean,
every once in a while.
Obviously, Jonathan Frakes
directed on the show.
Every once in a while, you
know, Marina Sirtis tweeted.
I actually got a tweet
from Garrett, Garrett Wang.
BRANNON BRAGA: Oh, no.
What'd he say?
SETH MACFARLANE: No,
it was very nice.
It was very kind.
But yeah, no, you know,
yeah, they've been great.
I mean, you know,
Robbie McNeill,
Robert Duncan McNeill came
and directed on the show.
There's a lot of people
who worked on those series
that we have crossed paths
with, and it's great.
I mean, we're all fans.
So it's cool to be
able to actually work
with these people.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
Thank you.
KEVIN BELK: I think the
next question is right--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Shall I stand up?
So it seems like a
really cool opportunity
to create an entire
new universe in terms
of characters in the world.
And all of the depth that you
can create for multiple seasons
and kind of create Easter
eggs and things that
are way out there.
So what kind of challenges
did you find doing this?
SETH MACFARLANE: Anyone?
[LAUGHTER]
SETH MACFARLANE:
Well, I mean, look,
"Star Trek," obviously,
it's model of a spaceship
as opposed to a sailing
ship is something
that emerged from science
fiction prior, from the 1930s,
from the 1940s.
I mean, there were other
shows that did that.
But they really were
the ones that kind of
put a memorable stamp on it.
And so the tricky thing
is, all right, anything
you do that deals with a
crew on a spaceship traveling
through space, you're
working in that territory.
And "Star Trek" and "Star
Wars" have trodden those paths
so heavily that
it is a challenge.
And so my solution
was really not to try
and twist myself into a
pretzel trying to all right,
you know, maybe, you
know, trying to do
something so exotic and new.
I just kind of
embraced, all right,
this is a bridge of a ship.
It's a crew on a spaceship.
Let's start there.
What can we do that's
new from that point.
And a lot of it was tone.
A lot of it was the thing of
putting the two command chairs
next to each other with the
captain and the ex-wife,
instantly turns this into--
it's now you're getting
into "Cheers" territory,
and that I haven't seen.
But it's a fun challenge
to try and find
the idea of an all-male
species, of Bortus.
And I haven't seen that before.
The idea of the Krill being
a technologically advanced
species that still clings
to their religion very,
very heavily is something that
this way I hadn't seen before.
And it's trying to
find new ways to,
look, the basis of your
series is the universe.
And so you should
never run out of ideas
if you're doing your job right.
Up here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LIZ HELDENS: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Aww.
JOSEPH PORRO: And
we need a new mike.
AUDIENCE: Does that, like, bump
really loud when I slant and--
that's awesome.
This thing's cool, Google.
KEVIN BELK: We didn't
invent it, by the way.
We just bought it, right?
Yeah, we just bought it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask
David a question, actually,
if that's OK?
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN BELK: They are
also people on here, yes.
You can ask them.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Because you wrote
for "Futurama."
And--
DAVID A. GOLDEN: I did.
AUDIENCE: --you wrote
an episode called
"Where No Fan Has Gone Before."
DAVID A. GOLDEN: I did.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Which I've
heard good things about.
I don't know if
you want to say--
So you wrote for another sci-fi
show with comedy and feels,
right?
And I was just
curious if you could
talk about the experience at
"Orville" versus "Futurama."
DAVID A. GOLDEN: Well, the
difference at "Orville"
is we-- well, thank you for
bringing up that credit.
Actually, Seth got me
the job on "Futurama"
after "Family Guy" was
canceled In its third season.
And he called them and got me
that so I owe him that, too.
But the difference
on this show is
we break the show as a drama.
That the stories
that we tell are
starting from a place of what
are the dramatic elements.
And when you're breaking
a show in animation,
you're really much more
focused on what's the comedy.
And so I think that's
the biggest difference,
that the core of this
show is much more related
to one hour drama, even
though there are, obviously--
this episode was
a flat out comedy.
But in general, that's, I
think, the biggest difference.
Otherwise, a lot
of similar things.
What's the character's story?
How are people
going to be involved
and giving the audience
what they want.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KEVIN BELK: Time for one more?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I know all of you
have been in the industry
for a long time, longer
than I've been alive.
So I guess--
[LAUGHTER]
SETH MACFARLANE: Fuck you.
Sorry about that.
DAVID A. GOLDEN: You
know how to make friends.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: On the
most basic level,
I want to know how
you deal with burnout.
How you sustain the
level of productivity
you're able to have in this
industry working in it so long.
And like, I work
in entertainment.
I'm doing my own thing.
And I experience burnout working
a couple of years on a thing.
Like, how do you do it?
SETH MACFARLANE: That.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH MACFARLANE: I'm
only half joking.
I don't know.
You know, you got
to take a break.
I mean, for me I get really--
I know it's coming.
And it's usually if
I've gone a long period,
like if I've gone, like,
you know, longer than eight
months or so without a break,
I start to get really, really
ornery, and just a little cranky
and a little short with people.
And it's not who I am.
So that is always
the indication,
OK, you're going
into asshole mode.
It's time to take a vacation.
But you just have to make time.
You know, take weekends off.
DAVID A. GOLDEN: Working
with good people helps, too.
If there's a lot of really
talented people around,
you can sort of doze off,
and let someone else do it.
And I am saying it jokingly.
But it is really
true on this show.
Everybody is a really
talented group.
And so when you're collaborating
with people, many of whom
are more talented
than you are, it
does help keep you
from burning out.
HOWARD BERGER:
Yeah, definitely, I
think with us on the makeup,
hair, costumes, and all that,
we just were feeding each other.
So even though we would have
three AM calls, which is always
Monday was 3 AM.
And we would still get up.
And I'd see Joseph.
And I'm always curious
to see what Joseph
was going to wear every day.
Because he wears something
different every day.
But it would feed us.
And we would just
play off of each other
and with Brannon and David and
Seth and the cast, you know?
And for the make up
department, we're
the first people
that greet the cast.
So we keep the energy high.
And that way, it
starts them off right.
And then we're the last
people to see them,
and we end the day high as well.
And then it's a
great day for them,
and they look forward
to coming back.
So it's being with
these great people.
SETH MACFARLANE: Are you
actually an early morning
person, or is it something
that you just had to, like--
HOWARD BERGER: No, I
am a morning person,
but I've now developed it.
Like, that's it.
Like, I'm up.
If I don't have to get
up, I'm up at 5 AM.
SETH MACFARLANE: Yeah.
HOWARD BERGER: It's crazy.
It's ridiculous.
Like I was up at
4:30 this morning.
Like, OK, what am
I going to do now?
SETH MACFARLANE: No, it's-- if
you were not the greatest guy
in the world and so talented
and I didn't love you so much,
I would want to
fucking kill you.
[LAUGHTER]
HOWARD BERGER: Thanks, Seth.
KEVIN BELK: And to wrap up just
very quickly, maybe go around.
But what's the biggest lesson
you learned from season one
that you'll take with
you to season two?
JOSEPH PORRO: I don't know
if we're ever truly happy.
We always are, like, maybe we
could've just moved-- you know,
that's who we are.
SETH MACFARLANE: That's
a very good point.
JOSEPH PORRO: And that's why we
like to get up and work 18 hour
days.
And there's a high
with the hard work.
We just really like
what we're doing.
SETH MACFARLANE: We're a bunch
of self-loathing people who are
just freaking never--
JOSEPH PORRO: And most
of us are divorced.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSEPH PORRO: Yeah.
SETH MACFARLANE: Honestly, for
me, I think more than anything
else, it's tone.
And you know, I've
said this earlier.
But it's, like, I've
seen a lot of shows
that have tried to do
the sci-fi comedy thing
and crash and burn.
And it's a thing
that-- in movies, I
think it's a little easier.
Because it's a one off.
It's big and splashy,
and you're not
being asked to invest in people
who aren't always surrounded
by amazing special effects.
Sometimes you're just
standing in a room talking.
And It's got to feel real.
And if it's too funny,
the stakes go away.
And if it's too serious, then
the show becomes too dark.
So for me, it's tone.
And I feel like,
interestingly, like we've
leaned, in recent episodes,
a little more into the drama
than I thought we would,
but it's kind of working.
And I follow a lot of feedback
online, as much as I can.
I love hearing what people
are saying about the show,
and I really do
take it to heart.
And that seems to be the overall
sentiment is, like, look,
we're buying these stories.
We're into these stories.
We're buying the
sci-fi of it all.
You don't have to throw a pie
in somebody's face once a page.
We'll stay with
you, which is great.
Because that's what's
fresh about it for me, too.
And so tone is
really the big thing
that I've learned a
lot about this season.
KEVIN BELK: Great.
Well, thank you guys
so much for being here.
"Orville" is on Fox,
Thursday at 9-10 Central.
So thanks so much, guys.
[APPLAUSE]